Back in the greenhouse, Tsung-Chi is
ready to begin his submergence
experiment. First, he transplants
germinated M202 and M202 Sub1
integrated rice seedlings into a large
submergence chamber. He then fills the
whole container with water, until the
rice plants are completely submerged,
and then leaves them for two weeks.
This simulates a potentially
destructive flood. There's going to be
a lot of sand, of soil, of dust,
and insoluble materials anyway, you
know, in the water, which blocks the
sunlight. Alright, so that makes it
even worse. As the plants go underwater,
it's all up to the Sub1 gene now. If it
does what we think it should, then
those plants should survive.
Well, two weeks later, he's back in the
greenhouse, measuring his submerged
plants. He measures each plant's height
while they're still submerged and then
drains the water from the tank. He then
removes the plants one by one, to
observe their overall health after
being underwater for two weeks. As we
stand them side by side, a familiar
sight once again greets us. Unmodified
M202 is limp, yellow, and struggles to
stand. Sub1, however, is sturdy, green,
and towering overhead.
In conclusion, it's clear to see the
winner. Sub1 truly is a triumph of
marker-assisted breeding.